[Música]
la guerra en ucrania cumple más de 40
días desde su inicio mientras las
potencias occidentales acusan a rusia de
posibles crímenes de guerra en lucha a
las afueras de kiev entretanto algunos
ciudadanos buscan la forma de seguir con
su día a día pese a los ataques rusos
tenemos informes
el presidente de perú pedro castillo
levanta la medida de toque de queda que
había decretado para este martes en lima
y callao el anuncio llegó luego de
reunirse con sus ministros y el congreso
y protestas en la calle por una medida
que la defensoría del pueblo declaró
como inconstitucional
comunidades indígenas de brasil acampan
frente a los ministerios de gobierno
para exigir ser retirada de un proyecto
de ley que busca que en sus territorios
haya explotación petrolera agricultura
comercial y minería
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 6 rodrigo se dan hoy es un
gusto acompañarlos comenzamos en ucrania
en la ciudad de kharkiv al noreste del
país allí las autoridades ucranianas
denuncian bombardeos repetidos en los
últimos días por el ejército ruso ante
la perspectiva de una nueva ofensiva del
kremlin una pareja decidió enviar un
mensaje de amor y resistencia a nuestro
equipo de france24 en el terreno acudió
a su boda
en medio de la devastación de un
edificio bombardeado en el centro de
jarquín un rayo de esperanza y una
imagen de amor
los recién casados anthony nastia han
decidido visibilizar su boda entre las
ruinas que seguirás cogiendo de la mano
cuando sea mayor para llamar la atención
sobre la situación de su ciudad golpeada
por la artillería rusa y mismo creando
a pesar de todas las atrocidades
cometidas en kharkiv ucrania todavía hay
un espacio para el amor
y para la bondad y la calidez solo este
tipo de sentimientos pueden ayudarnos a
sobrellevar la situación y a vencer
ahora
borrados
la ceremonia tuvo lugar en el metro
donde miles de personas de jarquín se
han refugiado de los misiles y la
artillería desde los primeros días de la
guerra
es un raro interludio de alegría
esto es para siempre sí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
gloria eugenia
el alcalde de jarque es un invitado de
honor ha estado trabajando para mantener
los servicios esenciales en
funcionamiento durante la ofensiva
a pesar de la ofensiva militar y de los
constantes bombardeos de los agresiones
rusos sobre la ciudad de jarquín el
pueblo ha encontrado fuerza y valentía
conocimos a anthony nastia el día antes
de su boda en un centro de voluntarios
que distribuye alimentos y medicamentos
ambos son médicos él es dentista y ella
enfermera como muchos otros ahora
trabajan incansablemente en el esfuerzo
bélico de ucrania
este paquete llegó ayer cuál es
exactamente
aquí sólo quedan personas valientes y
con coraje a su decisión me vi curioso
[Música]
y nada les echará de la ciudad
ganaremos definitivamente
permanecerán aquí hasta la victoria como
un escudo para ucrania y también para
europa
es difícil predecir si habrá un mañana
príncipe
si nos casamos mañana
podría pasar algo cualquier día y no nos
casaríamos
la amenaza de muerte se cierne sobre
jarquín que ha sido golpeada día y noche
durante más de 5 semanas
[Música]
anthony nast ya no tendrán su luna de
miel pronto
juran quedarse y resistir
mientras la perspectiva de una nueva
ofensiva rusa se cierne sobre su ciudad
[Música]
[Aplausos]
volvemos nuestra mirada a américa latina
porque en perú el presidente pedro
castillo levantó el toque de queda que
había decretado en lima y callao tras
días de bloqueos por la huelga de
transportistas que deja ya cuatro
muertos anteriormente nuestro
corresponsal en lima francisco zacarías
nos explicaba cómo queda políticamente
pedro castillo ante esta derrota las
marchas que continúan en la protesta
esta noche en el centro de lima están
pidiendo su renuncia porque consideran
que ha dejado al país en una situación
insostenible desde que asumió el poder
hace ocho meses por otro lado sus
opositores que en el parlamento exigían
la eliminación del toque de queda que
han empoderados como los vencedores de
esta jornada y este martes el salvador
cumplió diez días bajo régimen de
excepción por la recién escalada de
violencia que sacudió el país a pesar de
las denuncias de las organizaciones
internacionales sobre el incumplimiento
de los derechos humanos el presidente
buque le sigue con su controvertida
política de represión gabriel coll se
entienden los detalles
hace 10 días más de 80 personas
perdieron la vida en un fin de semana
por la escalada de violencia en el
salvador lo que llevó el presidente bucl
a imponer un régimen de excepción por un
mes llevando a arrestos masivos de
pandilleros desde la semana pasada
[Música]
a los que los tenemos 58 que estás
durmiendo en el suelo
fascinados 1 tiempo de comida
y en condiciones que estoy seguro que
ninguno de los pandilleros que están
afuera tienen enfermedades bukele
amenazó a los polleros de quitarles la
comida en las cárceles ya aumentan los
homicidios varias ongs ya han denunciado
las violaciones de derechos humanos en
el país las organizaciones sociales han
recopilado alrededor de 26 denuncias que
señalan violaciones de derechos humanos
durante las acciones del gobierno por el
régimen de excepción la mayoría de las
denuncias conciernen a detenciones
arbitrarias pero porque le acusó a las
pondrías de ser el brazo armado de las
organizaciones humanitarias las ongs
necesitan que haya baño de sangre para
poder criticar porque de eso viven para
eso son por eso han sido creadas
amnistía internacional denunció que el
discurso presidencial ataca y pone en
riesgo a las personas defensoras de
derechos humanos
en brasil las comunidades indígenas se
manifiestan para exigir que no pase un
proyecto de ley propuesto por el
presidente ya el bolsón aro que busca
que en sus territorios haya explotación
petrolera agricultura comercial y
minería el campamento cuyo nombre es
tierra libre espera que lleguen unos
7000 indígenas de la amazonía brasileña
veamos más con el informe de andrés
granadillo
buscan defender sus derechos cientos de
indígenas de brasil acampan a las
afueras de los ministerios del gobierno
como forma de protesta
existe hoy soy varios hoy hay varios
proyectos de ley en el parlamento que
abren los territorios indígenas a la
minería por lo que la ley 191 de hoy
refuerza estos avances dentro de
nuestros territorios y este acto aquí es
para decir que no que estos proyectos no
pueden seguir adelante
el proyecto de ley permitiría además la
agricultura comercial y la exploración
petrolera en sus territorios la
legislación respaldada por el poderoso
lobby agrícola también permitiría la
construcción de presas hidroeléctricas
en tierras indígenas más de 200 tribus
quieren que el gobierno no apruebe la
legislación propuesta por el presidente
de jair bolsonaro quien dice que los
indígenas tienen demasiada tierra
a veces su campaña- bolsonaro dijo que
si era elegido no iba a dejar un
centímetro de tierra de marcada los
pueblos indígenas
así que desde su campaña empezó a
declararnos la guerra
en brasil el 13 por ciento es tierra de
reserva indígena protegida y el 98 por
ciento de ellas se encuentra en la
región amazónica unas 400 comunidades
indígenas siguen luchando para que se
les reconozcan sus tierras ancestrales
el campamento tierra libre que estará
hasta el 14 de abril espera la presencia
de siete mil personas esta es la mayor
movilización indígena de brasil y
acabamos con imágenes de las playas del
estado de quintana roo en el caribe
mexicano hasta donde ha llegado un
recale masivo de sargazo una macro alga
proveniente del mar del mismo nombre
cerca de las islas bermudas las
autoridades del estado mexicano están
preocupadas por cómo puede afectar a la
temporada turística de semana santa
hasta aquí este repaso a la actualidad
internacional sigan con nosotros en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]